voilà qui ne va pas redorer l'image de
la politique hasard du calendrier
l'ancien président de la métropole
wilfrid schwartz était jugé aujourd'hui
dans la sphère de la gifle sur son ex
directeur de cabinet un geste qui avait
contribué à cette démission en juillet
dernier le maire de la riche qui a
d'ailleurs dénoncé à la barre un complot
visant à le faire tomber hélène il est
resté à la barre deux heures deux heures
à répondre aux questions de la
présidente du tribunal et du procureur
de la république jamais pourtant
wilfried schwartz n'a reconnu la gifle
donnée à son directeur de cabinet lui
parle d'une mise en scène d'une
manoeuvre pour le destituer au bout
d'une heure et demie d'interrogatoire
pourtant il craque et se met à pleurer
il explique qu'il en a marre que sont
soit associés à des histoires de
harcèlement que tout le monde le croit
coupable il ira même jusqu'à demander à
la présidente de le condamner à une
peine d'inéligibilité pour en finir avec
la vie politique on apprend aussi que le
soir de cette altercation wilfried
schwartz sera amené à l'hôpital pour
avoir pris trop de somnifères bref il
construit donc lui-même l'image d'un
homme déçu par les rouages de la
politique d'un homme piégé par ce proche
collaborateur qui aurait pactiser avec
le camp adverse les deux hommes pourtant
se connaissent de longue date ils se
sont rencontrés au sein des jeunes
socialistes c'est d'ailleurs wilfried
schwartz qu'il embauche à la métropole
en juillet 2020 pour être son bras droit
mais selon lui rapidement il ne ferait
pas la faire et leurs relations se
seraient dégradées impossible évidemment
de savoir ce qui s'est passé à huit clos
ce jour là dans le bureau du président
de la métropole pour le procureur
pourtant la culpabilité du maire de la
riche est clair il requiert actuellement
alors nous rendent nous enregistrons ce
plateau